steve barron ist von seinem posten beim
rechten nachrichtenportal bereit bad
news zurückgetreten der frühere chef
stratege von us präsident donald trump
war vorstandsvorsitzender bei breitbart
im zusammenhang mit einem neuen buch des
us journalisten michael wolf hatten sich
bahn und tram öffentlich überworfen
der präsident erklärte sein berater habe
im vergangenen jahr nicht nur seinen job
im weißen haus sondern auch seinen
verstand verloren
hintergrund ist ein treffen von trump
sohn donald junior mit einer russischen
anwältin im präsidentschaftswahlkampf
2016 rennen hatte kritisiert dieses
treffen sei unpatriotisch gewesen und
sprach von hochverrat seine kritik wurde
in dem neuen buch veröffentlicht
inzwischen ruderte bahnen zurück nennen
ein bindeglied zwischen den
erzkonservativen und trump hatte bis
august 2017 im weißen haus gearbeitet
im zuge eines machtkampfes verlor seinen
posten